so in the first movie I know that the
flute lady was inspired by a real
childhood fear that Andi had between the
two movies is there anything for you
that was inspired by a real figure you
have in the two films I'm um I'm a
producer so my feet are you know a
little bit hammer to the floor I've
never been scared of presences of ghosts
I can walk at home in the dark without a
problem it's sometimes I don't even turn
on the lights I'm scared of human beings
and guns that's what scares me sadly a
very reasonable fear to have one other
thing I really wanted to ask you about
is the use of VFX in this movie because
you guys are pros at creature VFX but
the aging technology is a whole new
beast right now so jumping into that was
there anything about applying that to
the young losers that really surprised
you well it was an exploration and II
was absolutely convinced it would work
he's our fearless leader and I go behind
him and he believed it was gonna work we
hired the most amazing team it's a house
called Lola they they they do a lot of
these things but they had never really
done this kind of d-- aging which is a
very particular one it's not about
making the skin tighter or less wrinkles
it's really about changing like
reversing the physiognomy and Annie had
a lot to contribute in and not because
he is a fizzy animist so he was the one
that would tell them okay I have to make
Jax had bigger that's how he turns back
into that's how you turn back the clock
the great thing is that Lola had as a
like blueprint the other film so they
knew where they were going they knew
exactly how they had to look but it
still was you know tricky and it was a
ten month process of Corrections /
Corrections / Corrections and all of the
kids needed different eh and not all the
kids have the aging but the ones that
did they only needed very different
kinds of teacher so it was a labor of
love it was really artisanal you know
it's funny how they it's sometimes I
talked to people about the effects and
they think it's like something you just
give to a house and they come back to
you you know five months later and
that's it it's a daily process we sit
and go through that day's drop it's
called like that and Andy makes notes
and notes and notes and it's it you know
you you have to have a constant rapport
with the with the VFX houses to get rid
oh yeah - art for me it is even more
credit than they already get it's a
hundred percent a true art form and
chapeau to the directors and producers
that stay on it you know because that's
how we get the best work out of the VFX
houses absolutely one story point I was
dying to ask you about because I am a
huge huge Jess Wexler fan you cast her
as a journal like give me all the Audra
scenes it was there ever a time when you
considered more scenes than just the
introductory scene at the beginning
there is another one that we've had to
keep in our back pocket it's a great
scene between her and McAvoy sadly as
you guys know this is a massive story we
were covering a huge book and once it
was shot it made it to I think up to two
versions two rounds ago of a film and
then we had
to say goodbye to it because we just
could not fit it in in the film and it
was about character you know and we have
you know so much richness in the
characters that we had to forego some of
that so you gave us three hours of great
concert I almost feel greedy asking that
question but she's just so talented you
guys will see it we will make sure that
this comes out not we don't want
additional scenes we want to put it back
in the movie so we'll make sure that
comes out I like the sound of that to
wrap up I know how important Bev spheres
in the first movie where to you because
she was one of the only ones who had a
fear that was real that could really ask
us in the real world in this movie
though there's a lot more of that so was
there any particular character who had a
fear that you're like we got a really
nail that in order to get it right well
all of them you know this is the and
this our fears that at my age are much
more relatable because we are in in that
generation our late 30s early 40s and
they are fears that will stunt your not
even your growth they will stunt your
life so we crafted them with a lot of
concern thinking overall in what had
happened to them as kids you know we sat
down with Andy Garry Jason then and you
know I think that's why it is a film
that is so appealing not only for you
know a younger generation but also for
our generation because it's the result
of you know what happens when you don't
you know truly truly work with your ears